[Music]  well people love fish out of water  stories so we came up with a sitcom for  tbs we think people are going to go nuts  for  and we've shot a little bit of it  take a look  what happens when the world's greatest  playwright meets the sun he never knew  he had  it's shakespearean son  [Music]  [Applause]  no sharper than a serpent's tooth it is  to have a thankless child  does that mean i can't borrow the car  you want to bounce over to 14th and nab  some popeyes i have no idea what you  just said  i need a rhyme for one's duty  big booty  and make us lose the good we oft might  win by fearing to attempt  i have no idea what you just said  it's shakespearean son  that's a winner right  that thing's going right to the top sure  is